the rev raphael warnock preaches from
the same atlanta pulpit that martin
luther king used to occupy
he's seeking elevation to a new job in
an election that could define america's
future
one of two democrats looking to oust
georgia's republican senators
and secure control of congress don't
just
focus on the man on the phone
behind the orange curtain once
reliably republican georgia was one of
the states that handed joe biden victory
in november
it now holds the key to how much he'll
be able to do in office
he came to georgia to rally support the
polls show it's a close
race politicians cannot assert
take or seize power power is given
granted by the american people alone
and we can never give that up it's
always
always the will of the people who must
prevail
so today tomorrow
vote make sure your voice is heard
election officials here are still
dealing with donald trump's attempts
to overturn the election as some have
said do you believe that what happened
in that phone call was an attack on
democracy
i'll leave other people to make the
decision on that i personally found it
to be something that was
not normal out of place and and
nobody i know who would be president
would do something like that to a
secretary of state trump is still
obsessing about his defeat
he came to georgia for his last rally as
president
hello georgia by the way there's no way
we lost georgia there's no way
the rig that was a rigged election
but we're still fighting it and you'll
see what's going to happen we'll talk
about it
even as he heads for the exit
republicans need his voters
and where america goes now will be
decided here
greg milam sky news georgia